if Ukraine is to be successful in the
spring offensive it desperately needs
tanks and it needs modern tanks it's got
lots of Tanks the danger is the current
generation are extremely vulnerable
with thousands littered on the
battlefields president zlinsky's asked
for modern tanks that have the
protection and the Firepower and of the
tanks available really there's only two
that meet those requirements the German
Leopard 2 and the American Abrahams tank
so far the UK has committed 14
Challenger 2 tanks this recent
Announcement by Germany is 14 leopard
twos the United States will be sending
31 Abram tanks we expect Poland to put
another 14 in still well short of the
numbers that sledsies asked for but time
almost certainly will generate more
foreign this will crucially be a very
decisive element in the war it'll
provide Ukraine with modern punch on the
battlefield and you don't have to take
my word for it the Russian rhetoric has
been enhanced over the last few days
with threatening narrative and the
Russians are deploying trying to deploy
their T14 Armada tank the Russians
realize just how important this military
capability will be
for all sorts of reasons of history and
its Constitution at the end of the
second world war Germany is reconfigured
as a purely defensive force and that
endures to this day likewise the
population in a recent poll said they're
very much supported uh Germany helping
Ukraine honored with defensive weapons
but it was another matter to Spring onto
the offensive and it's taken quite a lot
of political and diplomatic effort to
make sure that Germany isn't at the
Forefront of this decision but now it
has been unlocked